foreign
[Music]
that was intentional you handle this
what are you talking what happened we
doing my job hey come here man
okay use your head leave all that other
mess outside
I told you I wanted
[Music]
you get that's life
it's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
one day you came back the past came back
too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back your friends
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
cower bro and a fraud
try to spending half your life in a cell
watching somebody else live your life
enemies
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
and you make
it only Adonis Creed you're the best
pound fighter in the world three years
ago it's been a minute since you've been
out in these streets when I walked away
from boxing I walked away with some
unfinished business
[Music]
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
let him destroy everything you've found
everything we've built yeah
and start fighting
[Music]
thank you
foreign